Well,
I think that,
um,
you know,
there was a phase in human life that I
hope is getting over with where,
um,
leaders wanted to do the social
engineering where the idea of communism,
not the original idea of communism,
but the idea of Lenin Ism and Stalin Ism
was the state should control what you
are like state was more important than
the people and should form what the
people are.
And a,
that has been a devastating hold
approach.
It was the basis of nazi-ism its basis
of communism.
It's the basis,
uh,
Islamic fundamentalism.
And it's the opposite basis as our
founding founders and not just our
finders,
but going back to,
you know,
air saddle,
uh,
and that human beings have these
attributes and we should allow the
flowering of human being and the state
is there to serve us.
We're not there to serve the state.
And that's a very big deal.
And a,
it's a very big fundamental difference.
Whether first words of the constitution,
we,
the people,
the United States.
Now in these other philosophies,
it's we,
the state or the state does.
And then the people,
they form the people,
they make the people.
But that's a very debilitating
philosophy.
So that's generally what has been the
most important political fight in,
uh,
last century.